China ist auf dem besten weg rohstoffe auf dem mond abzubauen und könnte damit weltweit
einen vorsprung erreichen der für andere nationen dann nur noch schwer einzuholen wäre
Und im moment läuft alles nach plan und das ist nur ein gebiet auf dem china
Den westen wohl bald überholen wird und es ist eines der wichtigsten wie ist die lage. Jetzt den klicks und science fiction herzlich willkommen
In china läuft dem westen im moment in vielen dem run up und nicht wenige in der politik lassen die alarmglocken
klingeln gerade erst wurde der deutsche roboterhersteller kuka von einer chinesischen
Firma gekauft und wenn man sich in der app von 1 bot umschaut die segway gekauft haben und jetzt die
führenden hersteller in diesem bereich sind sieht man auch nur noch chinesisch
Im wahrsten sinne des wortes alle kommentare sind in chinesisch oder fast hatte ich habe mir schon überlegt ob man nicht schon bald
Chinesisch lernen sollte so oder so china übernimmt weltweit eine immer größere rolle und man sollte dabei nicht vergessen dass es ein
totalitärer staat ist sie sind zum beispiel führend in den bereichen elektro autos regenerative energien und vielleicht auch schon bald in der kernfusion
Denn darüber wird im moment ausgerechnet in der chinesischen raumfahrt nachgedacht die chinesen waren
2016 als erste in der lage ein wasserstoff plasma mit einer temperatur von
50 millionen grad für mehr als eine minute nämlich genau für
102 sekunden aufrechtzuerhalten ein kleiner aber bedeutender schritt auf dem weg zur kernfusion in ihrem experiment oder etwa
superconducting tokamak kurz ist reaktor wollen sie in diesen rekord schon bald
Um das zehnfache überbieten china ist übrigens auch anita den fusionsreaktor beteiligt der im moment in südfrankreich
In katar rasch gebaute der ideale brennstoff für die kernfusion wäre aber helium 3 und davon gibt es auf der erde
nur 15 tonnen also insgesamt auf dem mond während es mindestens eine millionen genau deshalb ist
China jetzt aktiv geworden was nur wenige wissen bereits vor fünf jahren haben chinesen einen rover auf dem mond abgesetzt und bis 2020
sollen zwei weitere missionen folgen ihr ziel den abbau von helium 3 auf dem mond vorzubereiten
Die zweite sonde soll dann beim proben wieder zur erde zurückbringen noch ist das alles hypothetisch und der abbau dieser riesigen mengen
Helium-3 ist nicht gerade leicht da es, im gesamten mondstaub gleichmäßig verteilt ist wem es aber gelingt eine technik für den abbau zu entwickeln
Der hätte ende dieses jahrhunderts vielleicht die kontrolle über den wichtigsten rohstoff für die menschheit ja wenn es neues dazu gibt dann
Halte ich euch natürlich hier auf dem laufenden wenn ihr kein video dazu und zu allen anderen dem verpassen wollt dann drückt mir
Genau hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst nicht mehr einen
Auf die glocke zu geben denn nur dann werdet ihr immer informiert wenn es ein neues video gibt ja hier
Also hier geht es weiter mit menschen wollen auf dem mond siedeln das plant nämlich die europäische
Weltraumagentur esa schaut es euch an wenn ihr wissen wollt und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt kann